[Music]
this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of candy crush saga
all right welcome to honest trailer
commentaries the show where we watch the
show about the movie
uh this week that movie is new mutants
uh we're gonna give you our behind the
scenes thoughts
on the film while we all watch it
together then we'll play some deleted
scenes and outtakes then ooh we got a
special treat for you we are gonna
release
the unreleased new mutants joe set visit
we are going to crack open that time
capsule see what
joe's uh looked like in uh what 2018
2017 i think it's 2017.
2017 yeah so long-awaited debut
like arya stark in this movie we will
see uh what they looked like way back
when
then we're gonna respond to comments and
questions from viewers like you uh
t's next week's honest trailer and uh
that's pretty much all she wrote if you
didn't see the intro this episode is
brought to you by
google play click the link in the
description to satisfy your gaming sweet
tooth with candy crush saga and download
now now now uh with me as always
are two bears um one represents all
that's good
and one represents all that's evil you
be the judge which one is which
uh lon and joe thanks for coming you're
much better at reading the
the sponsored tag than i am oh good
well you know i'm both great i'm a candy
crusher
myself so uh uh so i have that extra bit
of
enthusiasm uh it's it's taken the place
of quibby you know in
my life i don't can we do this again i
don't know if google wants you to be
like
katie corsaca will fill the hole in your
heart left by queen
i'm kidding i never used it ready i do
use candy crush
quite a bit um but the new mutants is uh
is a film that i thought was terrible
what say you
yeah man this is rough the only uh
silver lining and bright side that i'll
give to new mutants
is that we watched it together and we
haven't gotten to do that in a long time
for something
and that was nice but yeah that's fun
yeah we mystery science theater uh this
one we did like a zoom call where we all
press play at the same time and um it's
not good
this is a dog [ __ ] movie i'm sorry i
think what
bugged me about it though was it's not
like some movies are bad and it's like
well this was just conceptually it's
just a dumb idea for a movie
but like this is a good idea for a movie
like i like the idea of
taking the x-men world and giving us
this very different perspective and
doing it with a different genre like her
and putting it in one location like
this could have worked it's just the
execution is just
like fumbled from minute one like it's
just not a good way to do
this good idea otherwise for a move
i thought yeah yeah i mean if if movies
are at their best when they're like at
the intersection of
plot and character i feel like this had
no plot and no character
um i couldn't i couldn't hang my hat on
like one the protagonist like your way
in
danny danny moonstar is just giving you
nothing to me to me at least
and then all the other kids also seemed
like newcomers like they were all sort
of meeting each other it seemed like
nobody really had any grounding or
reality in that situation it was just a
bunch of
kids thrown together yeah it was really
bizarre
uh oh just you know like you said it
there was a way to do this movie like it
was there was an interesting premise but
i i think they they didn't hit anything
that i think they were trying to do it
was like okay danny's gonna be
the odd the odd woman out this new
person thrust in this weird situation
but all of them are asking each other
introductory questions too and it's like
you've been in the asylum for a minute i
think like
wouldn't you have already asked sam if
the minds were scary
it's very confused about stuff like that
i mean i think and and it's sort of what
spencer was saying we were saying this
while we were watching it the first time
they're they're not motivated the
characters are not properly motivated
like
i feel like they were like well they
want to get out of this place and
they're trapped by this bubble lady
and they can't and like that's not good
enough like
even a prison movie there's got to be
like a reason that the people who are in
prison
need to get out or want to get out you
know like like cameron poe's not just
trying to get off of conair because it's
a bad plane and he doesn't like it
he's got to get home to see his daughter
my daughter
like and that's that's what i think this
was missing is like danny like wants to
get away but like
her reservation's gone everybody she
knows is dead it just feels like she's
just like
that's a good point everybody else like
it seemed like they believed to some
degree that they belonged there
and belonged like uh uh separated from
society that they were a danger to
others you got to dangle something
for them breakout goes maybe it was
joining the x-men could have been a good
carrot sure every audience felt like
they were gonna do that like they were
already hinting like there is this other
place
it's a school that's a lot better for
mutants and i thought that's what it was
going to be that like oh we got to go
find xavier but no there's nothing it's
literally just well this place blows
let's get out of here
and then you find out that anja taylor
joy can teleport this was like
that's it there's solutions been there
for a minute one baby what are you doing
yeah well i mean lawn just dropped
watching buffy
get out with portals uh yeah you know i
feel like there was a way to do this
like actively they all get brought in as
new people
uh because their families were like you
need to get out we're having you
committed to this place
horrible things start to happen to them
as a group you know they're like okay we
gotta break out we've gotta go find
safety because they're doing horrible
things
up third act twist it's danny's own
fault or you know something but yeah it
was just this was we sit around we watch
buffy
it happens for a minute and this is a
bear the whole thing is act one like
character introductions just throughout
the whole film it never quite
gets its hooks into you and starts
moving because there's five kids and i
think there's five scenes
uh uh sequences like long extended
sequences of like
exploring who they are and their
backstory and then it's like well
we're 50 minutes into the movie and
we've just finished meeting everyone
how about a bear how about a bear
okay are you in a smoke bear does that
do anything for you you can do that
because this is now we know they didn't
know when they were making it but now we
know this is going to be the very last
fox x-men movie there is
and yet it still has that franchise
launch syndrome i feel like where
you feel them holding back because they
oh
we gotta set up mr sinister and essex
corporation all this but oh we can't
find out who
dr reyes is working for keep that under
wraps for part three and it's like
screw you guys like at this point this
is like the 50th movie in this just give
us the good stuff that you have
don't hold back now definitely is the
problem with the whole franchise and it
like it sums up the entire franchise
that they were constantly just like
making a pilot for the x-men like they
never knew what they wanted to do
they never knew what direction they
wanted to go in um
we met some mutants then they rebooted
those mutants and you know and so on and
so on and so on
and that's why we have the joke where
it's like this felt like
you know the fourth best movie of comic
book movie 1995 because there's
no energy difference to me between this
and 2000s like x-men just in terms of
like
here's here's the character obviously
that's a better movie but just in terms
of like um
spectacle and like uh plot
and the thing where they hold back
they're like embarrassed of the comic
book roots where they'll they'll wear
their normal clothes they won't use
their superhero name unless it's like in
a weird
illusion boy she's magic
um what are you some kind of cannonball
flashbacks of
13 that week like 13 x-men movies
9 10 somewhere in there we never saw
the x-men working together as a team in
their prime
four i was gonna say the first like
seven minutes of dark phoenix a film i
do not like
but the first like seven eight minutes
it's like you get this brief little
taste where it's like professor x gets a
call from the president it's like
a mission in space right away mr
president
i remember those those seven minutes i
was like oh this movie's actually good
everybody else is wrong and then that
only made the fall
more depressed during that when they're
like blasting into space and there's
like doing banter and the shuttle is
going up i i was like for a brief moment
it feels like the animated series and
you're like
they finally got us there after all
these years
finally it's the team is together
they're not breaking up they're not
coming together they're not forming
it's not been 10 years and they all hate
each other now
they're just the x-men and they're on a
mission and they know each other
and and it's like oh it's perfect and
then they lose it immediately even in
this movie
when they're like they want us to be
x-men i was like do you even know what
that means
like also your power is to turn into a
dog they don't need you
you're gonna be like an e d t or x-men
at best
like you know mascot jubilee
singing in the forest all right we have
we have a lot of trailer to watch and we
have a lot of set to visit
we got a last set to visit so let's uh
let's start watching the new mutants on
this trailer
which i cannot hear my headphones they
cannot hear at the moment
but we can add your video
magic perhaps use some of your magic
fixed it
also i know it's dazzler who sings in
the forest you guys not jubilee
yeah good catching misspoke for a sec
son of a [ __ ]
i was already mad at me for that one i
had to jump
in well guys let's talk a little more
about this movie and how bad yeah
it's pretty bad uh delete it again to
avoid that there we go
that just roll it from there it's fine
they've seen the rest of it though the
audience could hear it
oh nice lucky you
you're the ones who matter yeah
20th century studios okay that just
looks wrong
comes a film that was set to be released
in 2018
until it got delayed to avoid deadpool 2
delayed again to avoid dark phoenix
delayed again after disney acquired fox
delayed again
thanks to the rona and after all that
buildup and anticipation
looks like the 4th best superhero movie
of 1995
[Applause]
first of all i love that we found john
is a very flexible voice but
it used to be john saying something
there maybe that's in an outtake but we
decided to just go with this random
effect
that uh kevin found of just two people
clapping
which felt the most appropriate and i
think that's a solid list of 1995 horror
films
honestly i think we're being unfair to
the return of durant
dark man 2 3
this is a solid number 5. let's
let's if i'm being if i'm being fair i
would honestly go if i was doing this
list for real
batman forever number one tank girl two
i think three is dark man two
four stallone's judge dredd five new
mutants
that's my place fair enough and stalin's
judge just getting knocked down for rob
schneider if he wasn't there
maybe even maybe even in a play for two
and if we're counting shows at all
uh i might knock you new mutants out for
fox's mantis
[Laughter]
you know i missed mantis was that the
guy in like he was in a suit man
yeah that's like an inventor though
right it was an ironman-ish thing yeah
yeah but a bug but a book but right
the performance if you will yeah anyway
on a trailer for mantis let's go
keep going the new mutants
it's been a long strange trip at the
movies for x-men fans
from good to great
to bad to
worse learning
now roll the dice and enter a virus
field theater
to see what kind of experience will
bring the fox era to a close
then watch them crap out like the last
herd in a dump
before kevin feige can flush the whole
thing down the toilet
fuzz so i i think it's safe to say with
all the
delays and like the just the
circumstances surrounding this movie
that
disney didn't want anyone to see it i
mean
i think that's perfectly fair if you
paid for it fine but they were
they would rather just take the loss
than like have this further
tarnish people's there had there had to
be someone on the disney end that was
like can we just tell them it's bad
so that people stop screaming at us to
put it on disney plus or this and that
can we just
put a big banner up at downtown disney
like don't worry about it it sucks just
it's fine it's fine just go get a
cupcake the telling thing is that there
was all these rumors of reshoots right
and uh um the director came on and say
actually there weren't any which to me
feels like disney saw it as a lost cause
because they do reshoots for every comic
book movie they're like oh we gotta
tweak this we gotta make this work let's
add some more lists here and they're
like
you know what there's no saving this
just put it out as is
you also have to bear in mind these
companies are so desperate for
anything with a title with a star that's
high profile to put on these streaming
services like
they're losing billions by taking like
wonder woman it should be like we need
people to watch hbo like just today hbo
announced that industry
this like high profile drama series they
made they're going to dump the full run
this week on hbo max instead of letting
it play out on hbo because they're like
ah
thanksgiving please watch us uh and so
even in that environment where it's just
like anything just throw it up there
they were still like
maybe we'll put this out next year
we're still deciding whether it should
go to hulu or uh
nowhere this movie was so rough that
didn't
crackle exclusive yeah they were like
this might lose hulu's subscribers
and we don't want that like it was it
was literally like
they wouldn't even they didn't even want
to do that for like a day of play about
like whoa hey like arya stark is it a
new x-men movie
let's watch that nothing no they dumped
jakarta that's it um
this isn't on disney plus right this
isn't on disney plus
no no i believe it's on hulu right
i i don't i don't think it's anywhere
yet
but i believe it's going to come in the
next month or so to who
yeah it's not going to disney plus i
know that yeah got it it's never going
to distinguish their disavow
i believe hulu is gonna get it down the
road after a vod
run of a few weeks okay well they did
breath
uh all right keep going meet the new
mutants
who you'll come to wish for some kind of
suicide squad there's sam
the kentucky boy with the personality of
a column you know i had to go and work
in the minds of my dad
had to drop out to work in the mines
with his dad what's the call for
my dad gave it to me roberto
joe uh you've be the judge you're a
kentucky boy
how do you do with that accent hang on
let me find the call that my dad gave to
me when i
when i became a man around myself
picturing
vince vaughn and jon voight from
zoolander every time he talked about his
dad in the coal mines
that's an alternative flashback to them
[Laughter]
yeah no well we were more on the
agricultural side than the mining side
so here's the pine cone my dad
hey was it scary down in the pines it
was um
here's the mason jar full of bluegrass
my daddy gave to me he gave me this
uh a bucket full of dip and mountain dew
i'm all wrapped up on mountain dew chips
i i love sam guthrie so much he's one of
my favorite
characters obviously he's he's from my
state you know uh so i love
him i love uh paige guthrie i think
they're awesome characters
and you know to be fair uh sam
was kind of a weird like i don't know
wimp when new mutants dropped and he had
he had a long arc
over the comics of of becoming becoming
a mayan and you know stepping up and
being a leader
in the x-men but man he's just
i mean they're all a whole lot of
nothing in here except uh arya who is
doing her best to like hold this thing
together i think but
yeah a couple of a couple of mentions of
how scary it was in the mines
and and then he he tetherballs himself
and that was kind of it son of a [ __ ]
it feels like as much time as we spend
establishing everybody's like traumatic
backstory and like
which characters they get along with and
don't in the asylum
we never even really get a strong sense
for their powers like
he was one where i kept being like what
exactly like
he just like what if he gets these like
diseases of energy
hurt himself every time like does he
have to hurt himself every time or
they're like he's doing that on purpose
like i was confused
what they were trying to do with that he
just like
propels himself like a cannon like he
just launched
right he's invulnerable in the comics in
that state and so i guess the
implication is he just hasn't mastered
going fully in that cannonball state
to where he would be invulnerable and
can just bounce off stuff completely
without being
right that's what i think i was kind of
confused i mean obviously danny you're
sort of supposed to be like
she's figuring out what her power is so
i put that one aside but i was kind of
confused about the brazilian guy's
powers
and sam's powers and then i think
they're just purposefully like anya
taylor joyce powers relaxing
it's a great it's a it's a grab bag it's
whatever we need for this scene
let me walk you through sunspot's powers
were to put the movie over budget
um oh i'm on fire i know it's my power
but it's still freaking me out
rain is raining his dog she could turn
into a dog i think we all caught on to
that one pretty magically
i assumed it was going to be like like a
variety like she's beast boy but for
marvel like she could turn into
different animals but
no just one no just like i think they
were going to be like we're going to
launch a million movies with magic but i
honestly i think any taylor joy
like was like this is terrible and i i
feel like you can see on screen that
she's like this is no good
like yeah i mean she's pretty obvious
she's probably
for me the best part of the movie and
yet
still like the accent kind of threw me
and uh
yeah and i was very uncle i was very
unclear on what her powers were and what
her backstory was beyond like
they seemed to be going in like an abuse
direction but then it was like
demons i don't know he
is a weird character to begin with and
again it's one of those things
it's it's a challenge with her because
um
it took a long time in the comics to get
magic to the point where
she's got a sword and she goes to limbo
and she's the queen of demons
so it's a long trip to the fireworks
factory and pre that
she's not really interesting so
it's tough you either have a very
worthless iliana rasputin character
that's kind of dull or you go straight
to the fireworks factory and ask the
audience to deal with it
um so yeah her last name is rasputin
also that totally feels like one of
those like poochy scenes where they're
like
you know something like poochy but not
poochy we'll fill that in later and then
sometimes
it's like not her name's not restful but
something russian we'll fill it in later
it's like russian and vaguely evil let's
call her
you know we forgot to change yeah it's
really fair enough we gotta go we gotta
go
he's a claremont character like all of
those characters are like
uh gambit moanshare wahan wahawaha like
french french
uh nightcrawler uh you know why in the
comics
every every other word that uh
nightcrawler says is jean
josh like he's german you guys get it
like
same with yeah because she's colossus's
sister
um so yeah so i mean chris claremont
i'm just learning that for the first
time right now right
so yeah i mean the chris claremont era
of x-men was definitely like
um i don't know ethnicities for dummies
there
[Laughter]
roberto the human pot caller a d aged
arya stark who can warg into her
direwolf
danny moonstar a girl who lives by that
one native american proverb fitness
influencers post on their instagram
inside every person there are two bears
i asked the birds
which one wins he answered the one you
feed
and iliana we gotta we gotta we gotta
first of all have you guys seen the
hillbilly elegy
trailer where glenn close has maybe the
dumbest movie line i've ever heard where
she's like is it the one about the good
terminators
in between terminator bad terminator and
neutral
that's everything that's not just
terminators that's that's the entire
world of morality you can only be good
bad or neutral glenn close there's no
i don't know why you're supposed there's
lawful good terminators chaotic evil
terminators
i don't know why awful neutral terms
but that's people you could just say
people i mean one it's supposed to be
wolves right
i'm not crazy it's too weird i think
that they didn't want to get sued by
like
memes i don't believe in the fitness
inspo world
this is it's usually wolves yeah so the
other the other
but they had a wolf already ari is
already the wolf we need a winner now
when we did the set visit dog wolf bear
dog well fair so when we do when we did
the set visit
um a reporter asked uh the guys who
wrote and directed it they were like hey
this is so cool danny moonstar
such a cool character you're bringing
like a first nations actress in to
do this very this character so important
to a lot of people like are you really
like digging into
uh you know that's side of the character
her heritage and stuff and they were
like
i mean not really but
they did bring in at least they were
honest listen but look they're they're
trying to be yes you i feel like there
are four things that like white people
remember about native americans
uh because we're racist tp maze
the the two wolves slash bears and uh
horrible nicknames to call them and they
put two of the four in
various sports teams yeah i think they
googled native american proverb and
that's literally the first thing that
comes up yeah
i actually do think that's what happened
like
this literally feels like it was 10
minutes of what's up i need some
kind of thing dad said to her that feels
you know natively
and then they don't stop saying it
so much better because i think they
think they're being clever because like
an actual bear is gonna pop out
um it's just like figure out what
community
she's from like like like come up with
one
and then spend a few days like read
a book about about what that community
believes and they're there and then try
your
you know not like it doesn't have to be
like philosophical like
it doesn't have to be a complete
cosmology but like put a little bit of
effort
that sounds much harder than just saying
two bears and calling her standing rock
that's so it's really bad that stuff is
really bad they should have done
anything else can't wait for their
adaption of the stand
oh boy keep going and iliana who hates
being trapped in the facility
but since she can teleport must be
sticking around for the racism
this isn't the hospital pocahontas don't
know how to grow weeds do you no
what kind of indian are you hey standing
rock
you want the buffalo wing choice that
line
that sentence what is that sentence i
think that is the sentence that any
taylor joy saw in the script and was
like what have i signed on for
standing rock do you want a buffalo wing
what that combination of words has like
stayed in my brain
no one has ever said hey it doesn't even
make sense it's just like a collection
of vaguely
racist terms like i've never even said
offered a buffalo wing to something i
guess it plays real as like if you asked
a russian person to make fun of native
americans like they wouldn't quite get
it right
yeah this is the point in the movie
where because
it's sort of like if there were only
like five of them
and they're stuck in this like weird
creepy asylum from hell together like i
just don't feel like this would be the
dynamic like
hanging out snapping on one another in
like the break room yeah there aren't
enough people for clicks
exactly it's like it's like you're
trying to do the breakfast club but if
that detention room was like you know
there are the libraries in a void in the
middle of nothingness like no shermer
high school is out there like there's a
whole high school full of people like
yeah at this point
i think i still thought they were in a
whole facility and we were just meeting
this one group
i just i think really weird when you
discover they're the only ones that they
would band together in solidarity this
would be terrifying
from a purely like um from
from a writing point of view because i
know someone will be like oh
they get worked up by anything virtue
virtue sjw
from a from a character writing point of
view
like if if i if in the breakfast club
amelia west have has a character in
black and judd nelson
spends the whole movie calling him slurs
like there's no redemption for that
character like
just because he turns nice at the end
he's still just been
calling someone racist slurs the whole
movie and it's like very least
danny could give back like like this
person who's making fun of you for being
native american
talks like natasha and from from rocky
and bullwinkle like
just throw it back at her like oh you
sure you don't want some more vodka
stalin you know like anything like why
isn't she
there it's not a give and take it's
literally just like we're dumping on
this one character even though everyone
is a ludicrous ethnic stereotype that's
weird yeah
it's yeah it's a weird call it's it's
very strange do you want the buff
do you want one of your american buffalo
wings like
it was just such a weird choice to be
like she's
but she's a good person like i don't
know it was yeah
she acts like a checks like a john wick
villain for like
five sixths of the movie and then at the
end it's like redeemed yeah and then
they all walk off together and
i i guess uh uh once they get past the
gate she's like can you apologize for
calling me pocahontas
the
okay keep going experience a superhero
movie
that redefines low budget where they
barely even use their powers
use your power replay scenes from logan
and save money by not hiring a dialect
coach i'm seeing things
terrible nightmares lions and tigers and
bears oh my
you'll thrill when denny arrives at
xavier's empty off-brand mutant teaching
hospital
a place with exactly one employee so the
only latino student has to do the
cleaning
together this party of five will undergo
the old mutation
equals puberty metaphor what's happening
to me
plus the usual angst and horniness that
comes with making teens live together
all while the evil dr reyes undergoes
her sinister treatment plan
telling them all to chill a bunch of
times get some rest okay
this will relax you relax daddy calm
down
i want all of you to calm down control
control and
control okay this was supposed to be
rosario dawson until she
probably read the script or something um
and or invented some conflict
uh i don't really know reyes do you guys
know her from the
comics because i'm told she's a cool
character but i'm not seeing it yeah
she's like um
sorry i'm trying to remember exactly
she's like a
like a doctor who gets dragged into
their world
and if i remember correctly she's never
like a full-time ex-man
like she she goes on an adventure and
she's like this is insane
um but like lives near lives near
westchester so if they ever need her
like as a
you know if someone has a can't heal
factor
eight bullets out of their body like she
shows up to help out
but she's like a ultimately she's a good
person so it's again it's another
example of fox just being like we're
going to
and or even like transformers just being
like we're going to take the name of
something you know and we're just going
to kind of put it on
something different right but if you
also they're missing
they're missing a crucial scene where
where we establish
what the cover story is like there's no
here's what your treatment's going to be
i'm your doctor dr reyes and here's what
we're doing like
there's no front it's always just like
hey you're here i'm going to treat you
calm down like there's no explanation
for what she's doing or
why yeah it's just like
we just jump from hey you're here in
this weird facility to
all right hang out in the break room
watching buffy with your new cell like
there's no
like whatever it was it was very vague
because like so she's obsessed i guess
in retrospect she's like sifting through
or being ordered to sift through these
mutants to find like potential killers
right
but what about and does she just kill
everyone who isn't
who doesn't qualify or do they actually
get to go live on a farm somewhere
turning them into more effective killing
machines
except for the ones who were too
dangerous which she just had to
eliminate which is a very small
presumption which which also doesn't
make sense to me because
sinister nathaniel essex's whole thing
is making
like these super mutants that's why in
the comic and in the cartoons he's
obsessed with cyclops and jean grey
obviously jean grey is basically a god
and i don't know cyclops shoots lasers
out of his eyes
i don't know why that's special but um
but he's he's
he's like always his thing is genetics
and like
enhancing mutants and making like
unstoppable warriors and stuff like that
so you'd think
lady that makes your worst fears real is
like
high on his list and so you'd think that
the the plot would be
they find out that oh nope she's going
to get shipped away
to this horrible place to be used as
she's graduating to full-time experiment
and they have to save her
it's weird that he's like oh no too
strong she's got to go
yeah well right and it's too hard they
want to keep
all of that stuff off-screen like we're
supposed to be seeing it from the pov of
the
the patients who have no idea what's
going on but they they lean so heavily
in that way that it ends up being just
baffling and you never get a sense from
the amount of time
yeah with the amount of time that they
do all the compute the dumb computer
heads-up displays
give us at least give us like aol
instant messages from mr sinister
yeah right that's what i felt like i
felt like they didn't want to they
didn't want to show him because they're
like well we'll get brian cranston but
we'll do that in 2024. you know like
they
they they didn't want to spoil the
reveal of who's gonna be
yeah give me like some the fringe off
his jacket or something and then like
you know
give us like dr claw where we see like
his elbow in a chair
i'll get you next time magic something
something all right let's keep going
this movie's bad
okay is anything actually gonna happen
in this movie like a mr sinister reveal
or an x-men cameo
oh maybe a demon smoke beer ex-machina
okay the last one was a joke you guys
what the [ __ ] are you thinking
do you like horror no good neither does
this movie
ooh scary are you scared no
but every 20 minutes they'll remember it
was popular ones so they might as well
try some childhood trauma hallucinations
where each mutant gets a pg-13 spooky
flashback but without the scary clown to
make it all work
and that's the movie they meet up learn
about each other's fears
then a bear pops out you might as well
watch buffy instead they certainly do
[Music]
[Applause]
so much buffy we did not insert that
clip there
yeah i can't remember we're gonna get
copyright clean for this longer
yeah and i mean it really like take it
out of context that's crazy that's a
crazy amount of time you just
zoom in on them watching but it tips you
off to like what the
aim maybe of the movie was is to do
something like buffy but man they
totally whiffed on the fun factor
of buffy and like the wheat the knees
like it's gotten old but like it had
snappy dialogue
where this did not but yes it definitely
like that tips you off like oh i get
what they thought this might have a
chance of being
it is not okay
keep going so try to enjoy a film that
feels like a long pilot episode for a
show that cw
passed on that manages to be one quarter
asked horror flick
one quarter asked breakfast club one
quarter asked why a romance
and one quarter asked superhero movie
and when you add all that up
you get something that's 100 percent
complete ass
i can't believe that i killed my grandma
off to see this movie
starring somebody got caught well well
well if it isn't slipknot you can find
anything
dream yes hello
this is dog i don't want your life
in mother russia wig where's you flame
on
flame off flame off gives good domes
nightmare at the roxbury duh bear
and i kissed a girl and i liked it
the taste of her hairy dog lip
teenage mutants facing hurdles
nice title though okay danny can see
into people's fears but not into the
future so when she sees those clips from
logan and dr raya's head
is she scared of that scene happening or
do they just screw up the x-men timeline
again just for old time's sake
oh you guys i'm not gonna miss you at
all
it's an x-men tradition i mean logan
takes place they say it's like
20 29 or something and like i got every
appearance that that movie took place in
2017.
but also correct me if i'm wrong on this
i got i went down this rabbit hole
yesterday and did not to my
says get a satisfying answer the logan
future happens in the old x-men timeline
right like days of future past like
we have the first class timeline and
then we have the
you know yeah and logan are in the same
right so the fact that logan happens in
the future of this movie
means that new mutants is happening in
the old time so this isn't the first
class timeline
this is the hugh jackman original
like jackie janssen and um
and uh mars dog yeah um okay
that's weird like why would they do that
because then the future like if they
were going to make more of this movie
they wanted to be with james mcavoy and
yeah yeah wouldn't you think they would
want
their buildings they're building to an
encounter where the x-men fight the new
mutants and storm says do you know what
happens when a dog is struck by a light
same thing that happens to a frog
you guys trying to work out that
timeline is why i hate this franchise
yeah i mean i don't really care
like not everything has to line up
perfectly like the years in the mcu
whatever but it's just they keep like
it's like a series of rakes that you
could easily avoid that they keep
walking
out of their way to step on so oh yeah
this is not
spider-man uh uh put a date on a screen
that messed things up by six months or
whatever that was like this is yeah like
you said this is a
sideshow bob rake gag like over the
course of 20 years
uh looks like we have a little uh video
ins and outs so i will take this
opportunity to say uh thank you guys for
watching if you stuck with us so far um
we don't usually complain this much
about the movies uh but this was a
special treat
uh so hit like and hit subscribe and um
since it is still november for another
week
uh we are highlighting stack up which is
a organization that brings veterans and
civilians together through a shared love
of video gaming
serves the u.s and allied service
members and civilians to exist in crisis
intervention suicide prevention issues
concerning mental health through gaming
and community
november is they're called arms biggest
fundraising month so please check
check out stackup.org for more
information um what do you guys want to
do first outtakes or set visit
ticks yeah let's do outtakes okay well
let's play some outstanding
the best for last yeah save the best for
last please don't talk this off too much
oh yeah starring
little orphan uncanny must love dogs
wolverteen catholic rain
arya bark chill billy energy i think
it's the black lung pop
slag widow promise me you'll bury me
with my mutant arm
this is brazil brazilian air
dr dome dr anfiel
and smokey the bear and bears
defeats battlestar galactica
oops all rogues
but terrible x-men worst class
uh i remember my first kiss it was also
right on top of someone's grave
wolverine origins logan new mutants so
many x movies are about kidnapping
children
is simon kinberg q
yes yes he is i think we can all agree
yeah wow
wait for the next drop i i do feel like
oops all rogues
is very funny just as a title but if we
had actually made it like the captain
crunch cereal box
where it's just like simon kinberg like
whoops every character's rogue
oopsies yeah just two scoops of animals
yeah yeah yeah rolling into a bowl
okay it's been three years in the making
it's been it's been three years since
you visited
uh vancouver um boston boston okay even
better
um so this is gonna be the most uh
mind-melting shocking unbelievable
reveal
of your time here watching uh screen
junkies and phantom entertainment um
nothing will ever top this set visit uh
nothing has ever come close and nothing
ever will so joe
take it away and walk us through the
cinematic event of
2020 take us on a trip with you to
boston massachusetts
uh prepare to be astonished set the
stage set the stage
the year is 2017. yeah the year was
2017.
i was uh uh i didn't know what the
coronavirus was uh
i was uh 15 pounds lighter and um
i was sent to boston to cover the new
mutants which i was very excited about
when i asked defy how will i film it
they said
with your crappy samsung galaxy that's
already three years too old and i was
like
this thing and they were like yes we're
defy media
we don't have money um so i'm sorry we
have money
you don't have
i was like can i have a camera and they
were like are you smosh and i was like
no
and they were like no um
so i went to boston and uh really my
only uh directive was to convince arya
stark to say that she'd be in the next
game of thrones honest trailer which i
did and then felt gross about so i have
not included it in this
uh so this is a series of like pictures
and i don't know
clips so if you're interested in seeing
an actor do multiple takes of yelling at
a demon bear
uh enjoy i can narrate over it
uh yep here's uh here's magic uh
uh going at uh
that's that's the monitor given
direction like there's a bear
okay the bear's yelling they were like
yeah be mean to her uh oh her face is
turning into a smiley face
he just went rook to pawn seven oh god
oh no
queen's gambit um yeah there she yeah
she's yelling she got really upset about
it
okay there's another one go here's me uh
i'm
uh i'm on i'm on the set uh that's how
they made the snow place one more
one more that was fun you made me do
this and i was like
okay um by the way the box very nice and
very sweet
um here's arya uh yelling in that
cathedral
uh we weren't allowed to shoot any of
the cathedral because there was a giant
fake demon bear and they were like yeah
you can't
shoot that and i was like what can we
shoot and they were like our
our tech team has a ping-pong tournament
going on and i was like
cool you could go hang out at video
village that's just
a computer monitor like the whole thing
definitely felt
we all felt bad because every now and
then they would drag an actor over to us
who you could tell was like mid sandwich
you know like mid lunch she was just
like fine i'll talk to the nerds and i
felt so bad for them
um were they fully did they keep their
dialects going um
off-camera yeah oh fully immersed uh hey
joe it's me
sam guthrie hi y'all villains
um and then there were a couple of
photos i don't know if you ended up
getting the multan
uh if not uh i'll tweet them
um uh me with the lockheed puppet
yeah there we go okay there's me and
anya taylor joy with the lockheed which
i thought i was hoping lockheed
would be real the whole time and they
were just using a puppet as a stand-in
yeah oh look at that
gonna be played by andy circus there's
me and magic
uh those are all her swords all the
different kinds of swords she had to
shoot with
that's exciting okay and there's the
puppet
um and there's by the way the reveal
that the puppet was not only real but
just also the same size as the puppet
was very funny to me in the movie
um you'd think that they were going to
do a big reveal and he was a giant
purple dragon behind her i did
i did think it was going to be it no i
also thought it was a little pony i also
thought
not knowing the comics that it was a
pterodactyl until the very end
discovered that it was um and were there
any other pictures i don't know that's
the anyway that's uh what was
look i know we've made a big goof over
how we could never release a set visit
the reason we never released a set visit
is because it was bad oh come on joey
would have cut it together something fun
film never came out i mean the film
never came out yeah
eventually it was like so okay three
years later like this
small collection of clips um
i think if we put enough dubstep uh
behind that and title it like brie
larson said what
uh that we could easily get like 40 000
views yeah easily
footage i had to keep
like every 20 minutes i had to be like
is there somewhere i could charge my
phone
your camera yeah my camera um yeah so
there's somewhere i could plug in my rig
you guys cause yeah i've got all this
gear
and uh yeah that was that was that visit
it was very exciting to watch them shoot
uh reaction shots
of uh uh magic yelling at danny and uh
arya's seeing a bear
bravo you asked for it you got it people
um
that was that was truly life-changing
joe thank you thank you very much
finally releasing
thank you to fox and disney or whoever
gave the go-ahead to uh
you know let that out of the vault i
think that that will all never be the
same
that that set visit goes back into the
disney vault maybe
i'm so happy yeah maybe if you're here
again who knows the conversation about
that though is because we were always
like
what is the deal with that camera
because the you know they got purchased
by disney and all that and then
finally our own eric goldman reached out
to some contacts and was like hey we
shot this a million years ago and like
we've been very nervous about
showing it and disney was like oh yeah
we don't care yeah
they were like you could have shown it
like a week ago basically literally you
told us when we finally
asked what knew what yeah
uh don't care don't care yeah knew what
is that one of the uh country bears no
then we don't care
[Laughter]
phase five is all country bears fcu
so nothing about the country bears um
okay
back to country some music comments i
know we're going we're going a little
long but let's uh let's try to fit some
of these
before uh comments i do want to say
there was a correction
for lawn we do think in the chat that
logan takes place in the mcavoy
uh timeline because they get the blood
samples
in apocalypse they take the blood
samples from him that are then used to
make x-23
complications patrick stewart the whole
movie
i think that's a that's that's patrick
stewart beta
that's the other
i believe all of you nerds i i i'm
listening and you're all
more familiar with all of this stuff so
i'm gonna i'm gonna take your word on it
i i just think that's bad because then
you have the
the first class timeline and like you've
set up that it's gonna end
horribly tragically for all about like
the whole point should have been like we
have this new hope of
maybe there's a better way forward for
humans and mutants not like
yeah it's all dystopia no matter where
you go it says mutant killing dystopia
right and days of future's past would
have happened in the x3 timeline so it's
like
where did that happen but i guess then
they reversed it like it's just like
it's just oh well
now because of your heroes we get this
totally different also horrifically grim
but also
a buckle great job team i'm gonna say
this before we get into uh
uh audience comments i've just been sold
on this franchise
because it wouldn't be the x-men without
a massively
convoluted dying under its own weight
time travel
shenanigan continuity problem it
wouldn't be
hit the reset button many many times
yeah oops
yep all right exactly all dystopias
zachary delia writes uh that's very
terminator of them to be like no matter
what yes
right no matter what future it's like
judgment day sorry
yeah two more big flaws maybe noted in
deleted scenes no we didn't um
sunspot uh and i think reyes are meant
to be afro-latinx but did not
uh but not uh we're not cast that way
and the co-creator's last name is
misspelled in the end credits
i missed that yeah
yeah uh yeah no that's not in the
afro-latinx thing is not
in the movie at all i don't think not
mentioned or
yeah i don't know well that's an
interesting thing with his character too
is because he's like
uh you know you've got your tony starks
and your rich white nudes and marvel and
then you've all you also have um
uh sunspot who's rich as hell
and um you know a a
a minority uh character or a person of
color and yeah they didn't
that would have been interesting but
then in this they just have them doing
the dishes all the time and it's like no
he's like a weird
he's never touched a dish in his life
yeah he should hate this he should be
he should be paul rudd in wet hot
american summer when he's asked to clean
up his breakfast like yeah
that's what i mean like they gave them
back backstories but their personalities
don't really reflect
their backstories they always act like
he was just like teens at a high school
movie
and it's just like but this would be a
horrific
intense experience you wouldn't just be
like you're hanging out
in detention in high school yeah but
yeah at one point in the comics i think
he was financing the avengers so yeah
he's uh
he's interesting so he's doing all right
he's comfortable yeah
um all right let's go here adam holbert
writes does anyone think the horror
would have been better done with an
actual horror director like lei wennell
juanel or mike flanagan lee
lee winnell yeah is that the it is that
the
director no he made the invisible man
upgrade he wrote saw yeah
uh yeah he would have been great yes i
think totally for a hundred percent yes
i mean this was the uh um what's it
called uh
the fault in our stars uh right so i
think it was kind of out of his depth
when it came to action and horror
he doesn't know how to do a shot of two
teens lying uh uh next to each other and
then looking at the stars looking over
at the stacks of grass
grass yes it feels just like a teen
superhero movie with a few scenes that
sort of nod to her
rather than the horror movie i think we
were all sold on
yeah if you watch uh uh any anywhere i
can plug his house on netflix but
uh uh deals with some
i think similar approaches to what new
mutants was trying to do with horror
uh that would have been a great pick for
a director for something like this
yeah it's like it actually digs into the
psychology of it and it's
you know the characters are really sort
of like fleshed down and it's like i've
got a real sense of atmosphere and place
and all the things it reminds me of a
fan four stick in a lot of ways where
it's like
an odd toward body horror but if you
don't commit to it
yeah it just comes off as it's it's just
nothing
i don't know it's it's just like a
little homage like ah we like buffy ah
horror movie stuff right okay back to
the team mutant
superhero stuff all right i hope we
haven't overstayed our welcome but we're
gonna cut it uh we're gonna cut it short
because we've gone long
um uh thank you joe for your beautiful
beautiful set visit thank you so much
for doing that um
i hope that that gets clipped out so we
can kind of show it to more people and
preserve it for posterity and make that
dubstep montage
um that it really deserves uh and thank
you guys for watching so much
uh uh remember to check out stack up
remember to check out candy crush on
that google play store and come back
next week
because we will be
um go man uh
not cursing no we won't be cursing next
week so that's a good one joe
uh we hope you'll hope you'll enjoy and
we'll see you next week on australia
commentaries thanks again
this episode is sponsored by google play
download candy crush saga and discover
more
on google play now
[Music]
you